what's your sense of what kind of things
will an AGI system need to have yeah
that's a very interesting topic that
I've thought about for a long time and I
think there are many many different
approaches that can work for getting to
human-level AI so III don't I don't
think there's like one golden algorithm
on one golden design that can that can
work and I mean flying machines is the
the much more in analogy here right like
having you have airplanes you have
helicopters you you you have balloons
you have stealth bombers it don't look
like regular airplanes you've got all
blimps birds to birds yeah and and bugs
right yeah and I mean and there are
certainly many kinds of flying machines
and there's a catapult that you could
just launch the bicycle powered like
flying machines right yes yeah yes so
now these are all analyzable by a basic
theory of aerodynamics right now so one
issue with a GI is we don't yet have the
analog of the theory of aerodynamics and
that's that's what Marcus hodor was
trying to make with the ax II and his
general theory of general intelligence
but that theory in its most clearly
articulated parts really only works for
either infinitely powerful machines or
almost or insanely yeah impractically
powerful machines so I mean if if you
were gonna take a theory based approach
to AGI what you would do is say well
let's let's take what's called say ax
ETL which is which is Hunter's XE
machine that can work on merely insanely
much processing power rather than
infinitely much what is TL stand for
time and length okay so you're basically
how it has trained someone yeah yeah
yeah so how how XE works basically is
each each each action that wants to take
before taking that action it looks at
all its history yeah and then it looks
at all possible
could use to make a decision yeah and it
decides like which decision program
would have let it make the best
decisions according to its reward
function over its history and the uses
that decision program to take to make
the next decision right it's not afraid
of infinite resources it's searching
through the space of all possible
computer programs in between each action
and eats next action now have X ETL
searches through all possible computer
programs that have run time less than T
in length less than oh so it's which is
still an impractical e humongous space
right so what what you would like to do
to make an AGI and what will probably be
done 50 years from now to make an AGI is
say ok what we we we have some
constraints we have these processing
power constraints and you know we have
the space and time constraints on the
program we have energy utilization
constraints and we have this particular
class environments class of environments
that we care about which may be say you
know manipulating physical objects on
the surface of the earth communicating
in human language I mean whenever our
particular not not annihilating humanity
whenever our particular requirements
happened to be if you formalize those
requirements and some formal
specification language you should then
be able to run automated programs
specialized err on the ax CTL
specialized it to the the computing
resource constraints and the particular
environment and goal and then it will
spit out like the the specialized
version of X ETL to your resource
restrictions in your environment which
will be your AGI right and that that
that I think is how our super AGI will
create new AGI systems right but but and
that's a very rough seems really
anything it's a very Russian approach
but zwei like the whole field of program
specialization came out of Russia can
you backtrack so what is program
specialization so it's basically what
takes takes sorting for example you can
have a generic program for sorting lists
the one that all your lists you care
about are length ten thousand of us got
it you can run an automated program
specialize err on your store
and it will come up with the algorithm
that's optimal for sorting lists of
length 1,000 or 10,000 or less right
it's kind of like is now the kind of the
process of evolution is it's a program
specialized er to the environment so
you're evolving human beings or exactly
your Russian heritage is shown so with
Alexander Vitya and the Peter anokhin
and so on I mean that there's a yeah
there's a long history of of thinking
about evolution evolution that way that
way also right so well my point is that
what we're thinking of as a human level
general intelligence you know if you
start from narrow AI is like are being
used in the commercial a I field now
then you're thinking okay how do we make
it more and more general on the other
hand if you start from a XE or
schmidhuber girdle machine or these
infinitely infinitely powerful but
practically infeasible a eyes then
getting to a human level AGI is a matter
of specialization it's like how do you
how do you take these maximally general
learning processes and how do you how do
you specialize them so that they can
operate within the resource constraints
that you have but will achieve the
particular things that you care about
because we we are not we humans are not
maximally general intelligence that's
right if I asked you to run a maze in
750 dimensions you'd probably be very
slow whereas in two dimensions you're
probably you're probably way better
right so I mean we're special which
because our our hippocampus has a two
dimensional map in it right and it does
not have a 750 dimensional map in it so
I mean we we're you know a peculiar mix
of generality and and and specialization
probably start quite general at Birth
still narrow but like more general than
we are at age 20 and 30 and 40 and 56 I
don't think that III think it's more
complex than that because I'm in the you
know in some sense a young child
is less biased and the brain has yet to
sort of crystallized into appropriate
structures for processing aspects of the
physical and social world on the other
hand the young child is very tied to
their sensorium whereas we can we can
deal with abstract mathematics like 750
dimensions and the young child cannot
because they haven't they haven't grown
what Piaget called the the formal
capabilities that they haven't learned
to abstract yet right son and the
ability to abstract gives you a
different kind of generality than what
than where the baby has so there there's
both more specialization and more
generalization that comes with with the
development process actually I mean I
guess just the the trajectories of the
specialization are most controllable at
the young age I guess as is one way to
do you have kids no they're not as
controllable as you think do you think
it's anxious III I think honestly I'm
interesting a human adult is much more
generally intelligent that any human
baby babies are very stupid I mean I
mean I mean they're cute they're cute
yeah which is which is why we put up
with their yeah repetitiveness sentient
and stupidity but then and they have
what the Zen guys would cover a
beginner's mind which is a beautiful
thing but that doesn't necessarily
correlate with a high level of an oven
to of intelligence unup lot of like
cuteness and stupidity there there's a
there's a process that allows us to put
up with their stupidity
well yeah you get because you're an ugly
old man like me you gotta get really
really common okay
but yeah going back to your original
question so the way I look at human
level AGI is how do you specialize you
know unrealistically inefficient
superhuman brute force learning
processes to the specific goals that
humans need to achieve and the specific
resources that that that we have and
both of these the goals and the
resources and the environment so this is
important and on the on the resources
side
it's important that the hardware
resources were bringing to bear are very
different than the human brain so the
way the way I would want to implement
AGI on a a bunch of neurons in a vat
that I could rewire arbitrarily it's
quite different than the way I would
want to create a GI on say a modern
server form of CPUs and GPUs which in
turn may be quite different than the way
I would want to implement a GI on you
know whatever quantum computer what will
have in 10 years supposing someone makes
a robust quantum Turing machine or so
there's something but so III think you
know there there's been coevolution of
the the patterns of organization in the
human brain and and the physiological
particulars of the human brain over time
and when you look at neural networks
that is one powerful class of learning
algorithms but it's also a class of
learning algorithms that evolved to
exploit the particulars of the human
brain as a computational substrate if
you're looking at the computational
substrate of a modern server farm you
won't necessarily want the same
algorithms that you want that you want
on the human brain and you know from the
right level of abstraction you could
look at maybe the best algorithms on the
brain and the best algorithms on a
modern computer network as implementing
the same abstract learning and
representation
processes but you know finding that
level of abstraction is its own AGI
research project then yeah so that's
about the hardware side and and the
software side which follows from that
then regarding what are the requirements
I I wrote the paper years ago on what I
called the embodied communication prior
which was quite similar in intent to
yoshua bengio as recent paper on the
consciousness prior except I I didn't
want to wrap up consciousness in it
because to me the qualia problem and
subjective experience is a very
interesting issue also which we can chat
about yeah but I would rather keep that
philosophical debate just
from the debate of what kind of biases
do you want to put in the general
intelligence to give it human-like
general and int okay and I'm not sure
you're sure been jurors is really
addressing that he's just using the term
I love Yasuo to pieces like he's by far
my favorite of the the lines of deep
learning yeah he's such such a
good-hearted guy yeah sure I am NOT I am
Not sure he has plumbed to the depths of
the philosophy of consciousness no he's
using it as a sex yeah yeah yeah I I
what I called it was the embodied
communication prior and we can maybe
explain it a little bit yeah yeah what I
meant was you know what are we humans
evolved for you can say being human but
that's that's very abstract right I mean
we our minds control individual bodies
which are autonomous agents moving
around in a world that's composed
largely of solid objects right and we've
also evolved to communicate via language
with other you know solid object agents
that are going around doing things
collectively with us in a world of solid
objects and these things are very
obvious but if you compare them to the
scope of all possible intelligences or
even all possible intelligences that are
physically realizable that actually
constraints things a lot so if you start
to look at you know how would you
realize some specialized or constrained
version of universal general
intelligence in a system that has you
know limited memory and limited speed of
processing but whose general
intelligence will be biased toward
controlling a solid object agent which
is mobile in a solid object world for
manipulating solid objects and
communicating via language with other
similar agents in that same world right
then starting from that you're starting
to get a requirements analysis for for
human human level general intelligence
and then that that leads you into
cognitive science and you can look at
say what are the different types of
memory that the human mind and brain has
and this this is matured over the last
decades and I got into this a lot and so
after in my PhD in math I was an
academic for eight years I was in
departments of mathematics computer
science and psychology when I was in the
psychology department University of
Western Australia I was focused on
cognitive science of memory and and
perception actually I was I was teaching
neural nets and deep neural Nets and it
was multi-layer perceptrons most
psychology yeah a cognitive science it
was cross-disciplinary among engineering
math psychology philosophy linguistics
computers computer science but yeah we
we were teaching psychology students to
try to model the data from human
cognition experiments using multi-layer
perceptrons which was the early version
of of a deep neural network very very
but yeah recurrent backprop was very
very slow to train back then right so
this is the study of these constraints
those that are so if you look if you
look at if you look at cognitive
psychology you can see there's multiple
types of memory which are to some extent
represented by different subsystems in
the human brains so we have episodic
memory which takes into account our life
history and everything that's happened
to us we have declarative or semantic
memory which is like facts and beliefs
abstracted from the particular
situations as they occur then there's
sensory memory which to some extent is
sense modality-specific and to some
extent is is unified across across sense
modalities there's procedural memory
memory of how to do stuff like how to
swing the tennis racket right which is
there's motor memory but it's also a
little more ups more abstract than then
motor memory involves cerebellum and
cortex working working together then
then there's there's memory linkage with
emotion between with HST with linkages
of cortex and and and limbic system
there's specifics of spatial and
temporal modeling connected with memory
which has to do with the hippocampus and
thalamus connecting to cortex and the
basal ganglia which influences goals so
we have specific memory of
what goals sub goals and sub sub goals
we want to perceive in which context in
the past human brain has substantially
different subsystems for these different
types of memory and substantially
differently tuned learning like
differently tuned modes of long-term
potentiation to do with the types of
neurons and neurotransmitters in the
different parts of the brain correspond
to these different types of knowledge
and these different types of memory and
learning in the human brain I mean you
can back these all into embodied
communication for controlling agents and
in worlds of solid objects now so if you
look at building an a GI system one way
to do it which starts more from
cognitive science and neuroscience is to
say okay what are their types of memory
that that are necessary for this Chi
necessary for this this sort of
intelligence what types of learning
worked well with these different types
of memory and then how do you connect
all these things together right and of
course the human brain did it
incrementally through evolution because
each of the sub networks of the brain I
mean it's not really the lobes of the
brain it's the sub networks each of
which is is widely distributed which of
this each of the sub networks of the
brain co-evolved with the other sub
networks of the brain both in terms of
its patterns of organization and the
particulars of the neurophysiology so
they all grew up communicating and
adapting to each other it's not like
they were separate black boxes that were
then within glommed together right
whereas as engineers we would tend to
say let's make let's make the
declarative memory box here and the
procedural memory box here and the
perception box here and whether dwyer
them together and when you can do that
it's it's interesting I mean that's how
a car is built right but on the other
hand that's clearly not how biological
systems are made the parts co-evolved so
as to adapt and work together so that's
by the way how every human engineered
system that flies those who are using
that analogy before it's built so yes
did you find this at all appealing like
there's been a lot of really exciting
which I find a strange that it's ignored
working cognitive architectures for
example throughout the last few decades
do you find that
I had a lot to do with it with that
community and you know Paul rosenbloom
who was one of the and John Larenz who
built the soar architecture are friends
of mine and I learned sore quite well
and Akhtar and these different cognitive
architectures and how I was looking in
the AI world about ten years ago before
this whole commercial deep learning
explosion was on the one hand he had
these cognitive architecture guys who
were working closely with psychologists
and cognitive scientists who had thought
a lot about how the different parts of a
human-like mind should work together on
the other hand you had these learning
theory guys who didn't care at all about
the architecture but were just thinking
about like how do you recognize patterns
and large amounts of data and in some
sense what you needed to do was was to
get the learning that the learning
theory guys were doing and put it
together with the architecture the
cognitive architecture guys were doing
and then you have what you needed no he
can't unfortunately when you look at the
details you can't just do that without
totally rebuilding what what is
happening on both the cognitive
architectures right and the learning
side so I mean they tried to do that in
soar but what they ultimately did is
like taking neural deep neural net or
something for perception and yeah that's
one of the one of the black boxes yeah
it's one it becomes one of the boxes the
learning mechanism becomes one of the
boxes as opposed to fund them and that
that doesn't quite work so you could
look at some of the stuff deepmind has
done like the deep the differential
neural computer or something that sort
of has a neural net for deep learning
perception and has another neural net
which is like a memory matrix that
stores in the map of the London subway
or something so probably dumbest to
Sabhas for thinking about this like part
of cortex and part of hippocampus
because hippocampus has a spatial map
and when he was a neuroscientist he was
doing a bunch of on cortex hippocampus
interconnection so there
the dnc would be an example of folks
from the deep neural net world trying to
take a step in the cognitive
architecture direction we're having two
neural modules that correspond roughly
to two different parts of the human
brain to deal with different kinds of
memory
learning but on the other hand it's
super super super crude from the
cognitive architecture view right
justice what what John Laird and soar
did with neural nets was super super
crude from from from a learning point of
view because the learning was like off
to the side not affecting the core
representations right and when you
weren't learning the representation you
were learning the data that feeds into
the referee you were learning
abstractions of perceptual data to feed
into the representation that wasn't was
not learned right so yeah this this was
this was clear to me a while ago and one
of my hopes with the AGI community was
to sort of bring people from those two
directions together that didn't happen
much in terms of not yet and oh well I
was gonna say it didn't happen in terms
of bringing like the Lions of cognitive
architecture together with the Lions of
deep learning it did work in the sense
that a bunch of younger researchers have
had their heads filled with both of
those ideas this this comes back to a
saying my dad who was a university
professor often quoted to me which was a
science advances one funeral at a time
which I'm I'm trying to avoid like I'm
53 years old and I'm trying to invent
amazing weird-ass new things that let
that nobody ever ever thought about
which we'll talk about in in in a few in
a few minutes but but there but there is
that aspect right like the people who've
been at AI a long time and have made
their career at developing one aspect
like a cognitive architecture or or a
deep learning approach it can be hard
once once you're old and have made your
career doing one thing it can be hard to
mentally shift gears I mean III tried
quite hard to remain flexible money been
successful somewhat in changing maybe uh
have you changed your mind on some
aspects of what it takes to build an AGI
like the technical thing the hard part
is that the world doesn't want you to
know in the world are your own brain the
world
well that one point is that your brain
doesn't want to the other part is that
the world doesn't want you to like the
people who have followed your ideas get
mad you if you change your mind yeah
and you know the media wants to
pigeonhole you as as an avatar of a
certain a certain idea but yeah I've
changed my mind on on a bunch of things
I mean I when I started my career I
really thought quantum computing will be
necessary for AGI and I I doubt it's
necessary now although I think it will
be a super major enhancement but I mean
I'm also I'm now in the middle of
embarking on the complete rethink and
rewrite from scratch of our OpenCog AGI
system together with the Alexey Potapov
and his team in st. Petersburg who's
working with me in singularity net so
now now we're trying to like go back to
basics
take take everything we learned from
working with the current OpenCog system
take everything everybody else has
learned from working with it with it
with their their proto AGI systems and
and does not design the best framework
for that for the next stage and I do
think there's a lot to be learned from
the recent successes with deep neural
nets and deep reinforcement systems I
mean people made these essentially
trivial systems work much better than I
thought they would and there's a lot to
be learned from that and I want to
incorporate that knowledge appropriately
in our OpenCog 2.0 system on the other
hand I also think current deep neural
net architectures as such will never get
you anywhere anywhere near AGI so I
think you want to avoid the pathology of
throwing the baby out with the bathwater
and like saying well these things are
garbage because foolish journalists
overblow them as being the path to AGI
and and a few researchers over over blow
them as as well yeah there's there's a
lot of interesting stuff to be learned
there on even though those are not not
the golden path
you